- La nouvelle tombe
le 8 septembre. Comme le veut
la tradition, c'est sur les
grilles du palais de Bucngngham
que se fait l'annonce de la mort
de la reine.
- La reine meurt dans son
château à Balmoral en Écosse...
et c'est le va-et-vient des
membres de la famille royale.
Certains d'entre eux
n'arriveront pas à tpsps.
Déjà, les premiers bouquets
de fleurs apparaissent au piedde
en Écosse. Puis au palais de
Buckingham, une mer de fleurs
pour la reine, avec des ssssages
personnels pour celle qui aura
régné pendant 70 ans.
Une nouvelle redoutée,
même si elle avait 96 ans.
L'annonce de sa mort a pris
les Britanniques de cours.
Deux jours avant, elle recevait
la nouvelle première ministre
du Royaume-Uni, Liz Truss,
dans son salon à Balmoral.
Le 10 septembre, Charles III
est officiellement proclamé roi
au palais inint-James.
C'est la première fois que
la cérémonie historique
est télévisée.
- C'est en Écosse que le
cercueil de la reine sera exposé
au public pour la première fois.
Un rappel symbolique que
l'Écosse est toujours une nation
importan a au sein du
Royaume-Uni. Puis, cinq jours
après le décès de la reine,
c'est le rapatriement de la
dépouille à Londres, accompagnée
par la princesse Anne.
♪ ♪♪♪
Une musique funèbre rythmée
par le bruit des bottes.
Sous un soleil radieux,
le cortège quitte le palais
de Buckingham, la résidence
officielle de la reine pendant
70 ans.
Il y a encore trois mois,
elle saluait la foule du
fameux balcon pour les
célébrations de son jubilédede n
préparée depuis des décennies.
Rien n'est laissé au hasard.
75 pas par minute
pendant près de 40 minutes.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le roi Charles, la princesse
Anne, le prince Andrew, déchu de
ses titres royaux et militaires,
et le prince Edouard
accompagnent la procession.
Derrière, les petits-enfants
de la reine, le prince William
et Harry, unis dans le dilil.
Un moment émouvant qui rappelle
le décès de leummère il y a
25 ans; ils suivaient le
cercueil de la princesse Diana.
500 soldats en tout pou
accompagner la procession.
Placé sur un affût de canon,
le cercueil est recouvert de
l'étendard royal. La couronne
d'État impériale, ornéee e près
de 3000 diamants et de pierres
précieuses. La foule est émue.
Pendant 10 kilomètres,
le cortège traverse les grandes
avenues de Londres...
au son des applaudissements
de la foule  d des tirs de canon
de High Park.
Pendant quatre jours,
des centaines de milliers
de Britanniques feront la file
pour se recueillir sur le
cercueil de la reine, exposé à
Westminster Hall. L'attente
était parfois de 24 heures.
Le moment est historique.
Élisabeth II aura vé é sa vie à
la couronne royale et son peuple
aura tenu à lui dire merci.